never trust the woman who pulls you away  from your family that's like the biggest  red flag for me with the whole Harry and  Megan thing as a woman at school job and  it's your obligation to ensure the  family unit remains together what kind  of woman pulls a man away from his  brother father his grandmother that's  like such a red flag to me no matter  what your parents have done or no matter  what's happened to you as a woman I  think you should reconcile that make the  family come together then the way she  like insults his culture insults where  he comes from his Customs it's so  disrespectful that such a huge red flag  for a woman